BARTON ZWIEBACH:
Scattering in dimension.
And we will consider
a world that
is just one dimensional, x.
And, in fact, there's an
infinite barrier at x equals 0.
Infinite barrier, nothing
goes beyond there.
On the other hand, in here,
up to some distance R,
there could be a
potential V of x.
So we will have a
potential V of x,
it will have the following
properties-- it will
be identically 0 for x
greater than R, which
is the range of the potential;
it will be some function
V of x for x in
between R and 0; and it
will be infinity for x
less than or equal than 0.
This is your potential, it's
a potential of range R--
range of the potential.
And the experiment
that we think about
is somebody at x
equal plus infinity
throwing waves into
this potential.
And this observer can only
get back a reflected wave,
and from that reflected
wave, the observer
wants to deduce the type of the
potential that you have there.
And that's absolutely
the way physics
goes in particle physics.
In LHC, you throw protons
or electrons together
and you just catch
what flies out
of the collision with
all the detectors
and read that they
then deduce what
happened to the collision,
what potential was there,
what forces were there,
was there a new particle?
It's all found by looking at
what comes out and flies away.
So there's enormous
amount of information
on the potential from
the data that comes out
of you throwing
in some particles
in and waiting to see
what comes back to you.
So we will always have
this infinite wall.
And this infinite
wall at x equals 0
means that x less than
0 is never relevant.
And this is analogous
to R, the variable R
in radial coordinates for which
the radial distance is never
negative.
So in fact, what we'll do here
has immediate applications when
we will consider--
not in this course--
scattering in three dimensions.
So to begin this, we'll solve
the simplest case where you
have no potential whatsoever.
Now no potential means
still the barrier
at x equals 0, the
infinite barrier,
but in between 0 and R,
nothing is happening.
So you have just a
case of no potential.
Is the case where you
have the barrier here
and x is over there and up
to R, nothing's happening,
it's just the wall.
That's all there
is, just one wall.
So this is V--
no potential is V is
equal to V of x is equal 0
for x greater than 0.
And it's infinity for x
less or equals than 0.
So in this case, let's assume
we have an incident wave.
An incident wave must be
propagating in this way,
so an incident wave is
an e to the minus ikx.
And if you have
an outgoing wave,
it would be some
sort of e to the ikx.
These are the only
things that can be there.
They correspond to
energy eigenstates,
this is the de
Broglie wave function
of a particle with
momentum, in one direction
or in the other direction.
But let's combine them in a way
to produce a simple solution.
So this solution, phi of
x, will be the solution.
Will be a combination
that's similar--
e to the ikx and e
to the minus ikx,
and I should make the wave
function vanish at x equals 0.
At x equals 0, both
exponentials are equal to 1,
so if I want them to cancel,
I should put a minus.
So in order to simplify
this the best possible way,
we can put a 1 over
to 2i's over there
so that we have a sine
function, and the sine function
is particularly nice.
So we'll have e to the--
output like this--
e to the minus ikx
plus e to the ikx over 2i, and
this is just the sine function
side of kx, which
you would admit,
it's a V solution over
here, a sine of kx.
On the other hand, I can
think of this solution
as having an incoming
wave, which is minus
e to the minus ikx over 2i,
and an outgoing wave of e
to the ikx over 2i.
So this is the representation
of the solution when nothing
is happening, and the good
thing about this solution
is that it tells us
what we should write--
gives us an idea of what
we should write when
something really is happening.
So now let's
consider how we would
write the general
experiment in which you
send in a wave but this time,
there is really a potential.
So let's consider now, if no
potential was there and now
yes, potential--
so no potential here, so what
does it mean yes potential?
Well, it means you have this and
you have some potential there
up to some distance R,
and then it flattens out,
and something happens.
So in order to
compare, we'll take
an incoming wave, the
same as the one where
there was no potential.
So let's take an incoming
wave, which is of the form e
to the minus ikx
times minus over 2i.
But I must say here, I
must write something more--
I must say that x
is greater than R,
otherwise this is
not the solution.
You see, in the region
where the potential really
exists, where the--
goes up and down, you
don't know the solution.
It would take solving
the Schrodinger equation.
You know the solution
where the potential is 0,
so yes, this incoming wave is
the solution of the Schrodinger
equation in this potential
when x is greater than R.
And how about the outgoing wave?
Well, we would like
to write it like that.
So we'll say 1 over 2i e to the
ikx is also an outgoing wave,
and we have no hope
of solving it here,
finding what's
happening here unless we
solve a complicated equation,
but then let's look outside--
we're still looking outside.
But that cannot be
the outgoing wave.
This is the same as the other
one and there is a potential,
so something must be different.
On the other hand, if
you think about it,
very little can be
different because you
must have a solution
with 0 potential and--
you know these plane
waves going out
are the only things that exist.
And now you decide,
oh, if that's the case,
I cannot put another function
of x in there because that's not
a solution.
The best I can do is
multiply by a number,
because maybe there's
very little outgoing wave
or there is not, but then
I think of another thing--
remember if you had e
to the A, e to the minus
ikx plus B e to the ikx,
well, the probability current
was proportional to A
squared minus B squared.
And this time,
however, you have--
you're sending in a wave and
you're getting back a wave
and this is a
stationary state-- we're
trying to get energy eigenstate,
solutions of some energy
just like this energy.
And the only way it can happen
is if they carry the same
amount of probability--
probability cannot be
accumulating here, nor it can
be depleted there as well,
so the currents associated to
the two waves must be the same.
And the currents are
proportional to those numbers
that multiply these things
squared, so in fact,
A squared must be
equal to B squared,
and therefore we cannot
have like a 1/3 here,
it would just ruin everything.
So the only thing I
can have is a phase.
It's only thing--
cannot depend on x,
because that was an
unsolved equation.
Cannot be a number that is
less than 1 or bigger than 1.
The only thing we can
put here is a phase.
So we'll put an e
to the 2i delta.
And this delta will depend on
k or will depend on the energy,
and it will depend on
what your potential is,
but all the information
of this thing
is in this delta
that depends on k.
And you say, well, that's
very little, you just
have one phase, one number that
you could calculate and see,
but remember, if you
have a delta of k,
you could measure it
for all values of k
by sending particles
of different energies
and get now a whole function.
And with a whole
function delta of k,
you have some probability of
getting important information
about the potential.
So we'll have a phase there,
e to the i delta of k.
And let's summarize here, it's
due to current conservation--
the current of this wave and the
current of the outgoing waves
should be the same.
And also note that no extra
x dependents is allowed.
So this will produce
the J incident
will be equal to J reflected.
Now you could say, OK, very
good, so there's delta,
there's a phase--
should I define
it from 0 to 2 pi?
From minus pi to pi?
It's kind of natural to
define it from minus pi to pi,
and you could look
at what it is,
but as we will see from another
theorem, Levinson's theorem,
it will be convenient
to just simply say,
OK, you fixed the phase
delta at k equals 0.
At 0 energy scattering, you
read what is your delta--
unless you increase the
energy, the phase will change.
So if you have a phase,
for example, on a circle,
and the phase starts to grow and
to grow and to grow and to grow
and to go here, well, should you
call this pi and this minus pi?
No.
You probably should just--
if it keeps growing
with energy--
and it might happen,
that the phase
keeps growing with energy--
well, pi, 2 pi, 3 pi, 4 pi,
just keep the phase continuous.
So keeping the phase continuous
is probably the best way
to think about the phase.
You start at some
value of the phase
and then track it continuously.
There is always a problem
with phases and angles,
they can be pi or minus
pi's the same angle,
but try for continuity in
defining the phase when
we'll face that problem.
So let's write the solution.
We have this, so
the total solution.
We call the solution
with no potential phi,
this one we'll
call psi of x will
be 1 over 2i, the first term--
e to the ikx plus 2i delta minus
e to the minus ikx.
It's convenient to
pull out of i delta
to make the two terms
have opposite arguments,
so e to the ikx plus
i delta, and-- or e
to the ikx plus
delta parenthesis
minus e to the minus
ikx plus delta.
So this is e to the i delta
times sine of kx plus delta.
So that's this full scattered
wave, not the full reflected--
well, that word again.
This is the full
wave that you have
for x greater than R. So let's
write it here-- psi of x.
It's not the reflected wave
nor that it covers everything.
We include-- it's
for x greater than R,
but we include the incoming
and outgoing things,
because both are defined
for x greater than R,
so the total wave is this one.
And you notice that if
the phase shift is 0,
you are nicely back to
the wave function phi
that we found before.